[Musique]
salut joyux
anniversaire Mar
c'est
combientene vie
plus la
monésol
pourés
salut
salut j'ai besoin de nouveau
papier
fam ou 33h en voiture est-ce que
quelqu'un pourrait déverrouiller les
portières il faut appeler tout le
monde je veux qu'on les
trouve c'était quoi juste un petit n de
poule max tu as vu
ça où est
papa avant de connaître votre mère
j'étais un tueur agagage j'ai fui cette
vie et ils nous ont
trouvé mais c'est un
fling a ton mari et leur père c'est le
vrai moi mais qu'est-ce que tu es James
Bond dans monospace j'adore ce
monospace il faut que je sois l'autre
dan une dernière fois pour
nous ça te va très bien de jouer les
pères de famille c'est vraiment pas un
jeu c'est ma vie maintenant
bon j'aime assez la spontanéité du
nouveau
d une seconde une seconde
Go nouveau
record